hello
welcome back to the spectators
alternative conference
you are watching a special one-off
uh video podcast uh from our series
chrononomics stories from countries
turned upside down
and i'm delighted today to be joined by
sylvia sierra lee burelli who is the
milan correspondent for the financial
times
and cindy you the spectator's broadcast
editor and our resident expert
on china uh sylvia you
were regular uh during series one and
two of coreonomics giving us
updates from italy and after widened
parts of europe
when we first started chatting we were
going into lockdown it was certainly a
very different time
but no doubt covered 19 still dominates
agendas certainly here in the uk i
suspect to some extent in italy as well
can you give us an update on how things
are progressing now
um well they have massively improved
compared to
where we were in march or april
um in fact it seems italy is um
being taken as an example by other
european countries including in the uk
because
um for some reason we've managed to keep
uh
the second wave at bay at least for now
um cases are still below 1500
daily and hospital intake
is very very low so compared to
to the spring hospitals are faring a lot
better it seems they're also a lot more
prepared to face a potential second wave
people are still very very careful and i
think that has made
the large difference schools just
reopened a couple of weeks ago so i
think that is
going to be key um to see whether
numbers
will stay low or they will rise as a
consequence of schools reopening
but overall it seems life has gone back
to
a new normal because obviously it's not
normality but it's not what it was
um five or six months ago at this point
so seems to be progressing well um
but it's still early days and again i
think schools will be key in determining
whether we will face
a second wave or not and
cindy it would be great to have an
update on china as well
famously put wuhan and other parts of
the country into a very strict lockdown
when coronavirus broke out but you
recently penned a piece
for the spectator magazine talking about
pool parties that are back
up and running and wuhan an outsider
could believe that it is
it is as if the virus doesn't exist
anymore given
um how much non-social distancing was
taking place
so what's actually happening in china
does it feel like the virus is gone
there are people still living with it
daily
yeah so obviously china is a huge
country so caveat that
in front of everything pretty much um
but in most of the country coronavirus
is really a hot nightmare from earlier
this year um
people would have seen uh the social
media pictures of that pool party you
mentioned
kate which i didn't initially started my
piece by saying what could be better
than a pool party with beer and friends
and many people in the office that
actually looked too packed to be
anything fun at all and if you look at
those pictures it was really skin to
skin
and that just really shows that
coronavirus has been suppressed in china
according to official
numbers at least but there are no um
reports on social media so far
of any you know unknown virus as that as
did happen in december last year before
the authorities recognize
the virus so it does seem like uh china
has suppressed it and it hasn't done
that at
um at little cost it's done that through
closing down the country you know before
this
happened china was the fourth most
visited country in the world
but since it's happened no one has been
able to go into china unless you're a
chinese citizen and even then
you have to book one of these very rare
flights that are
still allowed to operate um only
recently had they started opening up to
more foreigners with exemptions like
long-term residence visas and that sort
of thing
so it's done that through a sort of new
zealand style closing down the entire
country
believing that even one case of
coronavirus is too many
a very strict quarantine rule when you
go into the country to track and trace
every single one of one person who could
be introducing
a new infection um and i guess the big
caveat is also to whether or not
you believe the official data on that um
for
now for the general public it does feel
like it's a thing of the past
although it was only on the weekend when
one of the state epidemiologists
uh warned that a second wave is also on
the way in china because
you know as the weather gets colder
people think that there's going to be a
resurgence especially as europe
goes back under um so so people are
vigilant
but it does feel like um very different
to what we're feeling in london
uh we'll come to comparisons in a second
it certainly does but cindy raise an
interesting point there because there
have been
a lot of criticisms and skepticism
around the official data
coming out of china many believe that
they've not been reporting
the genuine figures related not only to
cases but also hospitalizations and
number of deaths
i know that you were following the
social media coming out of china very
closely because actually at the height
of the pandemic for china there was a
lot of criticism of the government and
you could tell
perhaps that the figures weren't adding
up because of the response as to what
was actually happening on the ground
it's interesting that you say you're
following it now and it does seem to be
a bit quieter also
just those photos coming out of wuhan
and elsewhere in china showing that
people
aren't as strict around social
distancing might imply that people
do feel safer that doesn't mean that the
figures now are exactly exactly accurate
either but
it does paint a picture doesn't it that
things are under control
absolutely i think the one thing to say
is that mass testing isn't happening
there's no
equivalent of moonshot obviously there's
nothing like that happening here either
but
moonshot is not happening in china so
there could be cases that are being
missed a lot of
cases we know are asymptomatic anyway um
but the tests that
are happening show that infections new
infections are in the low double digits
for the entire country
and what is required to put a place down
into lockdown is just
you know rising cases of double digits
for seven days
to put an entire city of millions of
people into lockdown i think that's
utterly incomprehensible
to a lot of places in the west because
there's just no tolerance for it
whatsoever and social media provides a
huge um
hugely valuable tool for bottom-up kind
of expression
um people might think that china is so
top-down and authoritarian that people
have no outlet for their views
whatsoever they only believe the
official numbers
but that's simplistic because social
media allows you to
get your views on there of course there
are sensors that exist and
work on that but a lot of the time
they're not very good at their job
frankly and when the whistleblower
doctor liu and young died earlier this
year
it doesn't stop social media the census
doesn't stop social media from being a
flood
with so many messages of mourning for
him
um um criticism of government you know
they try their best
but you know people have a way of
getting around it so that's why i think
that
if there were these large-scale
infections happening um below the radar
i think that we'd be hearing much more
about it um on social media but we're
not at the moment at least
sylvia italy is the notable exception in
europe right now is the country that
still
seems to have this relatively under
control that has not been subject
to a second wave now we can debate the
language around a second wave what does
that actually mean does it simply mean
infections
or should it mean is the virus in the
capacity of your health service you know
we can have that debate but
almost regardless of which way you look
at it italy does seem to have this under
control compared to france spain and now
indeed the uk where
infections are increasing but very
notably we're having stricter lockdown
measures
put in place what do you think italy's
done differently that has so far
been able to put off the second wave you
mentioned that people are being very
cautious do you think they're being
extra cautious in italy or something
else going on
i think people are being extra cautious
because people are extremely concerned
for example i know parents who are not
sending
um their kids to school and have hired
teachers
to homeschool them so there is a lot of
concern for example teachers have to
wear face masks and face shields
students above six years old also
are required to wear face masks all day
um the the government has bought new
desks for
uh students so that can they can be
distanced then there aren't
two students sitting together so these
are just examples
um that go to show how um the government
is being extra cautious and people and
families are
extremely concerned still very concerned
and um
are being cautious but at the same time
i think uh the early lockdown measures
and the full economic lockdown that has
caused italy
lots in terms of economic performance
and gdp
is what is really um helping the country
right now because
um the gradual easing of um
the measures across the summer when
obviously it was very hot and people
were
living mainly outdoors um i i think
really helped
progress into the autumn and right now
um these measures that everyone has
very much gotten used to so the social
distancing the face masks uh the fact
that
um people can't um congregate
has really um helped the authorities
because i also think it's very similar
um to what cindy was saying about china
i don't think there is
a massive um testing going on and i
don't think that many people
are getting tested compared to what you
know the government is hoping or what
the government should be doing
so um what the numbers are telling us is
just what we know
um from the tests that are being carried
out but overall the fact that it's under
control
um i think is due to this combination
and obviously the first mover advantage
um in a way and the fact that um i think
you know
those remarks that boris johnson made
about um
the uk being a freedom-loving country
whereas italy and
germany perhaps not is maybe what did
make the difference because the fact
that people didn't really have a choice
and they just have to go with those
rules and have to go with those
guidelines
has really made a difference and also i
think make
people feel safer there has been some
backlash to those comments from boris
johnson that you just
brought up there's also some backlash to
his comments when he addressed the
nation
and talking about how wonderful was that
freedom that britain was a
freedom-loving country but then almost
suggested that was the reason that
infections were increasing and do you
think there's something in this idea
that because
italy at the height of the pandemic was
under stricter
lockdown measures in places like the uk
people are terrified to be
put in that position correct me if i'm
wrong sylvia but i remember you
and when we were doing the first series
of the podcast really couldn't go
outside and you had to justify
basically every time you walked out your
door now here in the uk you weren't
supposed to go out except for essential
trips
and to exercise but you were indeed
encouraged to go to the park to take a
walk to take a jog and it was different
in italy it was it was stricter
absolutely it was stricter and um it was
quite extreme
i wonder if um in those first few months
it was due to the fact that
um italians probably asked boris johnson
suggested
um you know need stricter rules and need
um to have their freedoms literally
limited in order to to follow in line
right because
italians are known um to sort of
oppose following rules um they don't
really like
authority and i guess in in the first
couple of weeks people didn't know
um i mean the government didn't know how
the public would have reacted so
definitely that was needed at that time
now
um i don't know what people elsewhere
um believe or feel but i i did realize
because i was in the uk recently
that um people are kind of becoming
concerned because
the uk doesn't have these stricter rules
for example we
um we went to a restaurant over the
weekend and um
this was actually last weekend where um
you know
staff was supposed to be wearing face
masks no one was
wearing a face mask and our groups just
decided to leave and i was the only
italian there everyone else was british
and they said you know
why at this point are there still um
waiters not wearing
face masks it's not okay we are
concerned so
i think you know um it really depends on
individuals but at the same time um i
think it is useful for governments
to sort of give an indication of how
people should be
behaving especially because i think at
least the perception here now
is that in the uk numbers are out of
control
and the government isn't able to manage
the situation
but then you also wonder if that is the
case then why are these new guidelines
quite lacks compared to what the
situation is being described as
so um i think that is creating some sort
of confusion
and um it's probably not very helpful at
least in this phase
okay if i can come in please um so
on the public opinion point i think it's
fascinating because when i talk to my
family in china
i say i ask them you know aren't you
worried that the government is hiding
at the official number the actual
numbers or for second wave and they said
well you know actually what
lockdown was so strict that if it
happens again we'll just lock down again
and that actually gave them peace of
mind
to know that there will be strict
lockdown coming so conversely they felt
like they were in safe hands because of
how strict
the government's lockdown was that they
felt people the government was taking it
seriously
now obviously that's just anecdotal so
i'm not saying that the chinese people
are happily taking lockdown
but i think we do see that replicated
across the world where to take something
like this seriously
public opinion seems to think is that
the stricter is better
and and that actually gives people more
uh
confirmation and we see that in the uk
with public opinion polls as well
70 of people think that the government
should be going down
stricter and that students shouldn't be
going home to christmas or anything like
that
so i think that's particularly
fascinating about the psychology of
public
opinion in what makes this pandemic goes
away
well that's interesting let's pick up on
that point cindy because as you know
here in the uk public opin opinion
overwhelmingly things that the
government should go stricter
we don't have loads of public
information about how many people are
actually adhering to the rules
sylvia mentioned when she was visiting
anecdotally she noticed that people
weren't necessarily following the rules
and restaurants with mass and social
distancing
and one of the first first big pieces of
evidence that we've gotten is from uh
ucl and kings college london which have
amalgamated over 20 studies
uh to show how many people said they
would self-isolate
if they had symptoms of covet 19 or were
told they were in contact with someone
who tested positive
and then how many people did
unsurprisingly people
pulled uh were said you know the vast
majority said that they would adhere to
the rules
it turned out that only 11 of people who
had been in contact with someone with
copa 19
were uh self-isolating and 18 of people
who had symptoms work
so there's a little bit of perhaps do as
i say not as i do stated versus
data versus real preferences do we have
a luxury here cindy in the uk though
to push back on some of those rules when
they actually start to impact us
in china if you are told to follow these
rules i imagine there could be much
stricter penalty if you don't yes
absolutely and this is where the
similarities end
so in china the public is made to follow
these rules for example
when you come go back into china after
flying there you're getting into a
quarantine of two weeks
the government will pay for you to stay
in a government organized hotel
in order to stay there but it's so
straight that you can't even go into the
corridor of the hotel room
so you have to stay in the room uh and
when my grandfather who's a heavy smoker
i went there she didn't she didn't
realize that her last cigarette would be
at heathrow
and she was then locked in this room
literally for a week
and they delivered all the food outside
and she was to grab the food when
when they left and because of her old
age she could then spend the second half
of that two-week quarantine at home with
my aunt
but even then the neighborhood watch
riggs an alarm
onto her door so that if she opened her
door it would send a text to a local
official who would then come rushing
saying what are you doing
um can we get you anything they were all
very friendly but essentially the
message was don't leave well
we'll make sure you're welfare but more
watered but don't do anything and
obviously we've also heard
on social media again of reports of much
harsher lockdowns
um in xinjiang the area where um
majority populations are uyghurs
in the capital there last month there
was a local lockdown in urumqi
and there were pictures of people being
handcuffed handcuffed to
um greats and grills because they had
gone out when they weren't meant to go
out so it really depends on local
enforcement and how it's
meant to be done i'm sure not everyone
can afford an electronic alarm
um but it is very done with a very heavy
hand and there's no
11 compliance it's just utterly
unthinkable
sylvia are italians feeling quite smug
when they look at the rest of europe
right now thinking that they got it
right or
is the attitude very much we just won't
know for years
really which policies were right who was
wrong
whether or not the swedish approach
turns out to be correct or
the chinese approach of the italian
approach and i could see a little
temptation at the moment
given where italy is compared to the
rest of europe to be a little bit smug
but are you trying to suppress that
um you know what i think italians don't
realize
they've been good at it and they're not
appreciating the government that much
um my colleagues at the ft um wrote a
report last week about how italy was
sort of setting the example for the rest
of europe and keeping
second wave at bay and the pickup of the
article
was incredible i think there was a point
where
the government spokespeople were press
releasing it
to tell people look this is how they see
us from abroad
um because the sense really is that you
know um
we haven't been that great and the
government hasn't been that great or
organized
uh there was lots of fuss about schools
reopening there was a point in august
where
um they had decided nightclubs could
reopen
and because of the nightclubs reopening
there was a major surge in infection
especially
um amongst the younger population and
obviously those were the people that had
to return to university or at school
so um there was you know a major alarm
about what is going to happen in
september if these people are infected
and they go back to school so
heavy criticism of the government for
deciding to um you know allow
restaurants and clubs to reopen um lots
of disorganization about the schools for
example
uh the policy of social distancing
students
or imposing face masks on the these
young kids was
very heavily criticized families were
concerned that they had to take the
temperature at home they wanted schools
to implement those rules
um you had images on social media and
um on television of students sitting on
the ground because these desks these
single desks hadn't been delivered so
they started their school year
sitting on the ground so there was lots
of criticism and also the economic
impact is extremely worrying and
concerning for a country
um whose public debt was already very
high and
um you know the economy here hasn't been
great for the past 10 years so obviously
this is kind of the last straw and
people are extremely concerned that the
government isn't doing enough about the
economy and about jobs so
um i don't think anyone is particularly
proud
of what italy is doing i think people
are now increasingly
realizing because they're hearing
reports from other countries in europe
and
um the us that this approach has
probably
been better or at least we've been lucky
we've been lucky because at this point
in time we're able to manage it and the
situation seems to be
more under control than it is elsewhere
but i don't think
um at this stage italians are
particularly
uh relaxed or proud and as i said i
think they're waiting for the numbers of
the schools reopening coming in
and they are expecting new lockdown
measures further down during the fall
or going into the winter and cindy
you live in london but
you are in contact not just with your
family but many experts
um over in china you host a spectator
podcast chinese whispers
so you're well in in touch with both
sides um
and one thing we haven't talked about
yet of course that matters very much to
the uk and to china
aren't simply their domestic problems
but this international race to get a
vaccine
and it is still thought perhaps
increasingly thought
that whichever country manages to produ
produce the first vaccine
and that can be distributed worldwide is
going to completely change its own
narrative
about how it fared through the kovid 19
crisis
uh the uk or england has had the highest
number of excess
deaths uh in europe thus far as report
was reported by the nns
ons the the uk had the largest economic
contraction of
any major country uh but of course china
has
all of the world eyes on it as to where
the virus originated from
and the lack of honesty that it put out
as the virus was starting to spread
both countries are desperate to be the
one to get this vaccine
how do you see this playing out on the
world stage and do you think if china in
particular
were to get the vaccine that could
change its narrative around covet 19.
so i thought um matthew lynn who wrote a
cover piece for us a few weeks ago
on the vaccine nationalism had a great
line in his page but he said
that a lot of countries are seeing this
as a moment of redemption and it really
is because
i don't think any single country has
dealt with this in a perfect way
and if you're locked down skeptic even
sweden has uh screwed up on its care
homes or if you're not even china has
you know screwed up on the initial
response and so no country has come out
of this perfect
uh perfectly what vaccine developing
countries have
is at least that hope of redemption um
we have oxford
china has uh five of the remaining uh
10 the final stages of the global
vaccine candidates are chinese
they are racing very very fast the
question is are they cutting corners
that people don't really want them to be
cutting china doesn't have a great track
record in public health it wasn't so
long ago only a couple of years in fact
when there was a huge national scandal
over a vaccine producer who had been
selling out of day vaccines and
mixing them up with new vaccines in
order to sort of make a concoction
she was fined heavily and is now in jail
so china has a
huge public health um reputation
domestically
for not being very good at that sort of
thing because of the regulatory capture
that can happen in a one-party state
globally as you mentioned do people
trust china who knows i mean pew
research
shows that europe europeans have never
had
lower opinions of china as a country so
if china really did
develop the first vaccine i'm not sure
that
politicians in europe and maybe sylvia
will be able to enlighten on this or
they perhaps italy is a slightly
different case because italy and china
seems to have
maintained some more level of
friendliness during this than other
places have
i'm not sure boris johnson for example
will be saying yes this is the one we
want to be adopting and especially when
you have your own
um skin in the game with the oxford
vaccine so i hope that
when when it comes to a vaccine those
scientists would make a decision about
whether or not they're valid and they
work and then the politics comes next
but i'm not entirely sure of that that's
what would happen
um for now though these five vaccine
candidates uh they are racing ahead one
of them
has been so confident in its candidate
that the ceo of the company has injected
himself
with inspecting as well as other senior
leaders of the company so you know if
they drop dead
i guess we know what's going on with
that but it is very much a
tight race and all the mistakes that can
never be higher
well that's one way to try to prove that
your vaccine's safe uh
sylvia in italy are conversations about
a vaccine at the top of the agenda they
certainly are here in the uk with oxford
and astrazeneca
in the race in phase three to try to get
the vaccine and in italy is there
discussion about how it might be
distributed
if we were to come up with one in 2021
um well there are a couple of italian
biotech firms uh that are working
on one but they're still um in the early
stages i think they're
about to end phase one and enter phase
two um
this week and it has been said that
these would uh be distributed to the
italian population
first but obviously these are just you
know uh great lines for politicians and
officials at these companies because
obviously it's very likely
um the uk or china or the us will get a
vaccine first
um i think italy is looking at the
european union
um because there were talks about uh
distribution agreements
um managed at brussels level
so at this point i think here um
the the vaccine is simply um everyone's
biggest hope
because everyone realizes that until
vaccine comes
it will be impossible to resume our
normal lives um
so i think the stakes aren't as
political as they are
elsewhere i'm also thinking about the us
for example where they have elections
coming up
um but obviously everyone is talking
about the vaccine as
um what will solve everyone's problems
and
i think um everyone here is keen to
believe whoever tells them that the
vaccine is about to come whether it's
next week or in two months because the
priority is just getting the vaccine
and resuming um a sort of normal life as
much as that will be possible
it's certainly sold here in the uk as
the silver bullet but that is a
dangerous game
if it doesn't come and it doesn't come
in a timely manner um we're
almost out of time so just to wrap up
i'm going to ask both of you starting
with you cindy
um is covered 19 still at the top of the
agenda
in terms of public discussion and
government discussion
uh in china and if it's not what is now
at the top of the agenda what should we
and the rest of the world be looking to
china to think um you know
this is where their focal point really
lies um so i think that's a really
interesting question
cover 19 is not at the top of the agenda
right now
and if you go on to chinese news
websites and i don't just mean the
state-run party run once but the ones
that exist
relatively independently like tyson you
know if you go down there you really
have to scroll down to find any recent
covered
stories because the infections are
supposed to be low and so there's
nothing
too dramatic happening there what has
caught the chinese um
imagination recently is the tick tock
and wechat bands
in the u k um because a lot of chinese
people think that this is just the way
uh for people listeners who don't know
uh trump is trying to ban those two
apps and tick tock is given a way out if
it can be
overtaken by an american company instead
of the chinese owner fight dance
um a lot of chinese people think that
this is just
literally trying to um overtake
appropriate a chinese company because
it's
successful others and pointing to the
fact that china itself bans
apps so you know who are you to point
fingers so there's a really interesting
debate going on in the chinese tech
community that's trickling out
to a wider population as well about
america is this the
america is america though now the new
enemy is are they going to be trying to
make things difficult for china in every
single space including
uh apps on social media and
sylvia what's the top of the policy
agenda in italy
covid and coronavirus and um
probably the eu recovery fund and how to
spend the money that is going to be
loaned to italy
italy is going to be the largest
beneficiary of um
the funds that are going to be loaned
from the european union so
obviously there's a lot of debate on
what projects should be prioritized and
i think the government currently has a
list that includes about 500 projects
which is way too many
um so directly or indirectly
and coronavirus is definitely at the top
of italy's agenda there's lots of
debates
to this day um on whether face masks are
useful or not what is going
whether people should get um a flu jab
because it might help
um avoid confusion over symptoms of
coronavirus
so directly or indirectly i must say
covet is top of the agenda
and what i mean when i say indirectly i
also mean um
economically and um in a comparative
sort of approach and trying to figure
out what the
money coming in from the european union
um will be used for
fascinating stuff cindy and sylvia thank
you so much for joining me for this
special episode of choreonomics to
those watching on at home or in your
office
grab a sandwich or a break for lunch but
be sure to be back by
2 p.m we have sir simon stevens chief
executive
of nhs england uh at 2pm uh
in conversation on msd's panel
chaired by our deputy political editor
katie balls so that's
one you won't want to miss stay tuned
again cindy and sylvia thanks so much
for joining me
have a great day
you